de nos patrocina la familia y dos
víctimas mortales que son denunciantes
en este proceso penal la familia de
celia ramos y la comunidad de américa de
santa
plantilla si aceleramos están
agradecidos a todas
cortaban a que las víctimas
sobrevivientes siguientes para que han
hecho posible que se abra investigación
policial este proceso no se detiene
durante el trámite de la ampliación de
la extradición de fujimori este proceso
continúa
bien y entre tanto que reparación buscan
las víctimas y sus familiares
sobrevivientes 25 años después
durante los 90 se llevó a cabo esta
política
fujimorista que configura crimen de lesa
humanidad el juez ha señalado este
mineral en derechos
que la denuncia tiene asidero por qué
el estado de la nación de la obligación
de garantizar los derechos sexuales y
los derechos de precios como veréis
humanos por lo tanto tenía que dar
por lo pánico las denuncias que dicen
que no se hizo así tiene verosimilitud
tiene un mérito a ser investigado
inicialmente la denuncia
data del año 2002 hubo intentos de
accionamiento de películas que se
lograron revertir
tenemos una nueva alumna por justicia y
por reparaciones integrales el gobierno
actual debe cumplir con la ley 3 algunos
119 sin más dilación no me sentí lunes
no te necesitan para reparar
integralmente a las víctimas de
solicitaciones portadas que este proceso
penal
y finalmente las esterilizaciones
forzadas que el fujimorismo hoy todavía
niega buscaron disminuir la pobreza del
país pero eso no pasó más de dos décadas
después como afectó esta estrategia
política la salud física y mental del
país
hoy podemos decir
que todas las pruebas que todas las
evidencias señalan que fue una política
de esterilizaciones forzadas que
configura un crimen de lesa humanidad y
que violó derechos humanos no fueron
delitos comunes no fueron delitos que
ameritan extensión
además no se hizo sólo por razones
económicas o sociales también hay un
componente de racismo también hay un
componente de un clasismo aquí se
entrevistó por cada mente mujeres con su
situación de pobreza por su situación
entre mujer indígena que es hablante
albina o amazonía mujeres de instrucción
mujeres jóvenes y sin alegría y por eso
esta investigación judicial puede
concluir en una situación futuro juicio
oral por crímenes de lesa humanidad ya
sea en la modalidad de genocidio tortura
o la esterilización forzada como lo
consideran las normas internacionales de
derechos humanos y las normas de estos
entes muchos